A estas alturas de 2021 quizás no os hayáis
dado cuenta.
Pero este año ha habido Juegos Olímpicos.
El evento deportivo más importante del mundo
acaba de celebrar en una de las ciudades más
fascinantes del mundo: Tokio, la capital del
manga, los samuráis y el sushi.
Pero nada de eso ha servido para llamar vuestra
atención.
Y no lo digo yo, lo dicen los datos.
La audiencia de Tokio 2020 en NBC es la más
baja desde los Juegos Olímpicos de 1988
La caída de las audiencias ha sido catastrófica.
A nivel global se mueve entre el 25 y el 30%.
Y claro, desde VisualPolitik nos preguntamos
cuál es el verdadero interés de los Juegos
Olímpicos.
Hace años, los Juegos Olímpicos eran el
sueño húmedo de cualquier gobernante.
Parecía una verdad absoluta que organizar
unos juegos olímpicos eran lo mejor que podía
pasar para “poner a tu país en el mapa”.
Los Juegos Olímpicos de Barcelona 92 sirvieron
para mostrar que España era un país moderno
y democrático.
Los de Pekín 2008 mostraron el poderío de
la nueva China.
Sin embargo, Tokio 2021 ha mostrado las peores
vergüenzas de Japón.
Y no, no sólo es por que el coronavirus haya
chafado todas las expectativas.
Es que realmente ha sido un fracaso lo miréis
por donde lo miréis.
Atentos.
Estudio de la Universidad de Oxford: los Juegos
Olímpicos de Tokio son los Juegos de verano
más caros
Los que seguís VisualPolitik recordaréis
que hace 2 años ya pronosticábamos por aquí
que Tokyo 2020 iba a ser una ruina.
Y eso era cuando pensábamos que, al menos,
Tokio recibiría turistas.
Pero con la pandemia del Coronavirus, Japón
ha tenido que cerrar las puertas del país.
Así que no han tenido ningún turista.
Cero.
Rien de Rien.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Hasta qué punto
estos Juegos han sido una catástrofe para
Japón?
¿Veremos consecuencias políticas?
Y lo que nos toca más de cerca a todos: ¿Estamos
ante el fin de los Juegos Olímpicos tal y
como los conocemos?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(MABOROSHI NO ORINPIKKU) OLIMPIADAS FANTASMA
Lo de Tokio y los Juegos Olímpicos es una
relación de amor-odio.
Hablamos de un gran éxito y demasiados sinsabores.
Veréis, a lo largo de la historia, Tokio
ha presentado la candidatura olímpica hasta
5 veces.
La primera vez fue en 1940.
Los gobernantes de Japón querían mostrar
el poderío de su imperio.
El problema es que en 1940 acababa de estallar
la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Así que Japón tuvo que renunciar a organizar
estos juegos olímpicos.
Eso sí, en la memoria colectiva de Japón
aquellos Juegos de 1940 se recuerdan como
los maboroshi no orinpikku, es decir, las
olimpiadas fantasma.
Dos décadas después Tokio volvió a la carga
para intentar hacerse con los Juegos de 1960.
Pero no tuvo nada que hacer frente a la candidatura
de Roma.
Sin embargo, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
a la tercera fue la vencida.
Tokio fue la sede de los Juegos Olímpicos
de 1964.
Japón aprovechó para decirle al mundo que
ya se había convertido en una democracia
capitalista.
La capital nipona, reducida a cenizas en 1945,
emergió como una moderna metrópolis.
Se construyeron nuevas carreteras e infraestructuras
como el tren bala, del que tenéis más información
en el video que le dedicamos en nuestro canal
Megaprojekts.
Aquellos fueron los primeros Juegos retransmitidos
vía satélite; todo un milagro tecnológico
Made in Japan.
Y como estos juegos salieron tan bien, los
Japoneses quisieron repetir la experiencia.
¿El problema?
El problema es que el espíritu olímpico
ha cambiado, y mucho.
Los Juegos han duplicado sus dimensiones.
Acude el doble de atletas, procedentes del
doble de países y con el doble de competiciones
en disputa.
Todo esto se traduce en que organizar los
Juegos hoy día supone una fortuna: carreteras,
hoteles, villa olímpica, estadios… y todo
ello para usarse sólo durante un mes.
El mes que duran los juegos.
Y diréis ¿Qué pasa después?
Pues podéis preguntar a los brasileños.
Río luce apocalíptica un año después de
los Juegos Olímpicos
Os presento la realidad de los juegos olímpicos.
En las últimas 3 décadas, no ha habido ni
una sola olimpiada que haya sido rentable.
Sin embargo, poco de eso ha importado.
En 2019, el 90% de los japoneses estaban entusiasmados
con los juegos de Tokio 2020.
Así que los yenes nunca faltaron.
Y creedme, hablamos de muchos yenes.
El presupuesto inicial era de 7.300 millones
de dólares.
Pero el comité organizador reconoció oficialmente
que estas cifras se elevaron hasta los 12.600
millones de dólares.
El aplazamiento y las medidas de prevención
contra el covid-19 añadieron otros 2.800
millones para hacer una la factura final de
15.400 millones de dólares.
Sin embargo, una auditoría del Gobierno japonés
estimó en más de 28.000 millones de dólares
la inversión total.
Esta auditoría incluye el gasto de infraestructuras
que estudios como el de la Universidad de
Oxford excluyen porque consideran que son
inversiones que Japón tarde o temprano tendría
que acometer.
En este sentido, los Juegos de Pekín o los
invernales que Rusia organizó en Sochi se
llevan la medalla de oro en cuanto a los más
caros de la historia.
Pero si nos ceñimos al coste de organizar
los Juegos, los preparativos para esas semanas
de competición deportiva, Tokio no tiene
rival.
Han tirado la casa por la ventana porque estos
Juegos eran la gran apuesta del primer ministro
Shinzo Abe.
Una oportunidad para decirle al mundo que,
después de décadas de estancamiento económico
y catástrofes naturales, Japón estaba de
vuelta.
Sería un gran honor para nosotros albergar
los Juegos en 2020 en Tokio, una de las ciudades
más seguras del mundo, ahora... y en 2020.
Algunos pueden tener preocupaciones sobre
Fukushima.
Déjeme asegurarle que la situación está
bajo control.
Shinzo Abe, primer ministro de Japón (2012-2020).
Otro objetivo para el Gobierno era demostrar
que el país no se ha quedado atrás respecto
a Estados Unidos o China a nivel tecnológico.
Durante décadas Japón fue la referencia
en lo que respecta a ordenadores, televisiones
y videojuegos.
Ahora querían aprovechar los Juegos Olímpicos
para marcar un nuevo hito tecnológico en
la Historia del olimpismo.
El problema es que dudo que muchos se hayan
dado cuenta.
NHK transmitirá 200 horas de los Juegos Olímpicos
de Tokio en 8K
Efectivamente, la televisión pública japonesa
se ha gastado una pasta en ofrecer retransmisiones
en 8K ¿El problema?
Que casi tiene televisiones en 8K.
Con lo cual, pocos se han dado cuenta de la
calidad de las transmisiones.
Dinero para nada.
¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque la historia es aún peor.
Atentos.
GAME OVER PARA SUGA
Akira es uno de los comics japoneses más
míticos de la historia.
Los otakus que estéis viendo este vídeo
no necesitáis que os explique lo que es.
Pero para los que no lo conozcáis, se trata
de un comic publicado en 1982… pero ambientado
en 2019.
En el comic, la ciudad de Neo-Tokyo está
a punto de celebrar unos Juegos Olímpicos.
Y, la verdad es que el retrato distópico
de Akira se corresponde bastante con la realidad.
Los Juegos Olímpicos se llevarán a cabo
bajo el cuarto estado de emergencia por coronavirus
en Tokio
Está claro que estos Juegos han sido únicos.
Para empezar han sido en 2021, la primera
vez que se celebran en año impar.
Y todo para que al final las restricciones
sanitarias hayan impedido que hubiera público
en las gradas.
Aún así, el sucesor de Shinzo Abe, el primer
ministro Yoshihide Suga, mantuvo su empeño
en celebrar los Juegos a toda costa.
Y todo esto a pesar de que la pandemia está
provocando cada día casi 10.000 muertes a
lo largo del mundo.
Sin embargo, Japón se ha empeñado en organizar
los Juegos Olímpicos… aunque sabían que
no iban a rentabilizarlos.
Una decisión más difícil de entender que
el final de Akira (Esta va para vosotros,
mis queridos otakus).
Es más, para poderlos organizar han tenido
que poner unas restricciones de lo más rocambolesco.
Y atentos porque aquí es cuando se calienta
la historia… o más bien todo lo contrario.
Se permite el alcohol pero no se distribuyen
condones en la villa olímpica de Tokio
¡Habéis oído bien!
Desde 1988 se repartían condones en la Villa
Olímpica.
Pensadlo bien, los deportistas son gente joven,
con buen cuerpo, con la testosterona por las
nubes… vamos, que se montan unas orgías
nachovidalianas.
Pero, en época del covid, nada de condones.
Pero los japoneses han ido aún más lejos.
Atentos.
Las camas que se instalarán en la Villa Olímpica
de Tokio serán de cartón, esto tiene como
objetivo evitar la intimidad entre los deportistas.
Las camas podrán soportar el peso de una
sola persona para evitar situaciones más
allá del deporte.
(Que digo yo, YOSHIHIDE SUGA, Primer Ministro
de Japón ¿No era más fácil posponer un
año más los juegos olímpicos?).
En realidad no sólo lo digo yo.
Esta era la opinión mayoritaria de los japoneses.
Un 40% pedía un nuevo aplazamiento; otro
40% quería directamente que Tokio renunciara
a los Juegos.
Pensadlo bien: mientras los japoneses tenían
que soportar un montón de restricciones,
han tenido que ver cómo llegaban al país
50.000 deportistas de casi 200 países distintos.
Y todo ello porque…
Japón ha manejado el Covid-19 bastante bien.
Tiene 126 millones de habitantes, con una
población notablemente envejecida.
Y aún así las muertes rondan las 17.000
desde el comienzo de la pandemia.
Estos datos se deben a la seriedad con la
que los japoneses respetaron las restricciones.
Sin embargo, el 20 de agosto, 12 después
de la ceremonia de clausura, hubo casi 26.000
positivos, el día con más contagios desde
que comenzó la pandemia.
Y alguno pensará: ¡Bueno!
¡Pero alguna rentabilidad habrán sacado!
¿no?
Se preveía la creación de 2 millones de
empleos y un efecto positivo para la economía
nipona de 128.000 millones de dólares gracias
a la inversión, al turismo y al aumento del
consumo.
Y sí, muchos pensaréis que esas previsiones
siempre están infladas.
Pero es que el resultado ha sido próximo
a 0.
Ni siquiera han podido vender una mísera
entrada.
Tampoco han sacado provecho las grandes empresas
japonesas.
Se gastaron un total de 3,600 millones de
dólares en publicidad.
Pero los ciudadanos estaban tan cabreados
que Toyota retiró toda su publicidad relacionada
con los Juegos a pesar de ser uno de los principales
patrocinadores del COI.
Así que, claro, al final el legado de Tokyo
2020 son las facturas.
Os recuerdo los números: 28.000 millones
de dólares, de los cuales 15.400 es simplemente
el coste de organizar el mes de competición.
Pues bien, de ese pastizal, todos menos 6.700
millones de dólares van a salir de los bolsillos
del contribuyente japonés.
Hablamos de una millonada con la que se podrían
construir 300 hospitales o 1.200 escuelas
de educación primaria.
Como podéis imaginar, lo que ha batido records
es la impopularidad del primer ministro Suga.
Un hombre para el que ya no habrá más pantallas.
Ni de 8K ni HD.
Yoshihide Suga dejará el cargo de primer
ministro de Japón
Con Suga fuera de combate, su sucesor tendrá
que enfrentarse a unas elecciones generales
antes de que acabe noviembre.
A ver quién les cuenta ahora a los japoneses
que hay que subir los impuestos.
Porque la deuda de Japón ha alcanzado ya
unas dimensiones tan colosales que a su lado
Godzilla parece una lagartija.
Y muchos os preguntaréis: ¿pero esto tiene
consecuencias para el resto del mundo?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA LLAMA OLÍMPICA SE APAGA
Los Juegos Olímpicos son como las bodas.
Es un derroche de dinero para disfrutar de
un momento que luego pasa muy rápido.
Aún así, organizarlos es el sueño de cualquier
país.
Todavía recuerdo cuando Madrid optaba a organizar
los Juegos Olímpicos.
Ya podía uno tener cuidado con eso de decir
que estabas en contra, que todo el mundo se
te echaba al cuello.
Al final Madrid perdió ante Tokio.
Pero a los españoles nos dejó grandes momentos.
Con este inglés tan impecable, la por entonces
alcaldesa de Madrid, trató de persuadir al
Comité Olímpico Internacional.
Mirad qué maravilla.
And I assure you, no one celebrates life like
Spanish people do.
There is nothing quite like a relaxing cup
of "cafe con leche" in Plaza Mayor.
Or a quite romantic dinner in El Madrid de
los Austrias.
Muchos os estaréis preguntando que qué tengo
yo en contra de los Juegos Olímpicos.
A ver, independientemente del desembolso de
dinero, lo peor de todo es tener que ganarte
a los miembros del COI.
El Comité Olímpico Internacional es una
de las organizaciones que mejor vive del mundo.
Cada vez que visitan una ciudad candidata,
reciben un trato de lujo.
Y, según se han revelado en varias ocasiones…
las camas que les ponen no son de cartón,
precisamente.
El COI expulsó a varios miembros por corrupción
a finales de los 90.
Habían sido comprados para llevar los Juegos
Olímpicos de 2002 a Salt Lake City.
Pero no era un caso aislado.
La capital de Utah había adoptado esta estrategia
después de perder ante Nagano 98.
La candidatura japonesa regaló ordenadores;
la ciudad mormona repartió caramelos y sombreros
de vaquero.
También se desveló que varios miembros del
COI habían pedido a la candidatura de Melbourne
para 1996 coches nuevos y gastos pagados en
los mejores burdeles de la ciudad australiana.
Melbourne no aceptó y aquellos Juegos se
celebraron en Atlanta.
Ya os lo he dicho: los miembros del COI no
duermen en camas de cartón.
Está claro que los deportistas se entienden
entre ellos dentro de la Villa Olímpica.
Pero a los del Comité Olímpico hay que darles
un trato profesional.
Y con denominación de origen para que no
tengan dudas sobre donde hay que celebrar
los Juegos.
El problema es que la gente ya les tiene calados.
Los fracasos económicos de Rio o de Tokio
son notorios y la audiencia televisiva sigue
cayendo.
Por eso cada vez hay menos interés en organizar
el megaevento olímpico.
Y los miembros del COI se están cansando
de ver noticias como estas:
Hamburgo vota 'No' en el referéndum de los
Juegos Olímpicos de 2024
Juegos Olímpicos de Roma 2024: la alcaldesa
Raggi dice no: "El sí a la candidatura es
irresponsable".
De repente el COI se encontró con solo dos
candidaturas para organizar los Juegos de
2024: París y Los Ángeles.
A la vista del panorama optó por una decisión
salomónica.
Pues oye: París 2024 y Los Angeles 2028.
Por lo tanto, está claro que algo está cambiando
en el olimpismo.
De tener a varias candidaturas pegándose
por obtener el favor del COI a ver como las
candidaturas prácticamente se presentan a
escondidas.
Casi casi que el COI ahora va por el mundo
suplicando: oye, mirad a ver si queréis celebrar
los Juegos en vuestra ciudad.
Y sin comerlo ni beberlo, nos hemos encontrado
con que ya tenemos sede para los Juegos de
2032.
No tenía rival, pero aún así mirad el teatrillo
que hacen para darle emoción.
The International Olympic Committee has the
honour of announcing that the Games of the
35th Olympiad in 2032 is awarded to Brisbane,
Australia.
Dos cosas tengo claras ahora mismo: una es
que el 90% de vosotros os acabáis de enterar
de lo de Brisbane.
La otra es que, para ver a quién colocarle
los Juegos, los del COI vieron el vídeo que
hicimos sobre “¿por qué Australia es rica?”.
Dentro de 11 años, cuando se celebren esos
Juegos, estoy seguro que os acordaréis de
VisualPolitik.
Pero mientras tanto la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que los Juegos de Tokio se recordarán
como un símbolo de superación o como una
catástrofe?
¿Tenemos Juegos para rato o la llama olímpica
corre peligro de apagarse definitivamente?
Y lo que es más importante: ¿Qué ofrecerías
al COI para que tu ciudad organice los Juegos
Olímpicos?
Queremos conocer posibles candidaturas así
que podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.